Ghost Recon wildlands is out March 7
2017 and we got the chance to explore
Bolivia and Ubisoft Paris's latest
sandbox adventure we played for around 4
hours on the PlayStation 4 Pro and got
to check out two of the games 21 regions
with a game as big as Ghost Recon
wildlands there can be a lot to take in
but here are 7 things you can expect
from the tactical shooter number one
gunsmith and character Smith one of the
coolest things about 2012's Ghost Recon
Future Soldier was the gunsmith gunsmith
allowed you to modify guns to your
heart's content and guess what it's back
with gunsmith you can swap out triggers
stock scopes barrels and just about
everything else in order to make your
own death-dealing frankenstein machine
however in order to unlock new parts for
your guns you'll need to find them
scattered around bolivia i've been
wanting one of these wildlands also
introduces character smith now you can
have your very own frankenstein carrying
around your Frankenstein gun character
Smith was actually pretty robust the
bill didn't have everything unlocked but
there were a lot more options than what
we saw in the division last year number
2 co-op is better in twos while there
may be plenty to do in Bolivia it all
feels kind of empty every mission I took
on in solo my tactics felt kind of
limited by my AI squad but that changes
with a few buddies by your side or maybe
not by your side at all just because
you're in a co-op game doesn't mean you
have to stick with your friends you can
set out and do your own thing or split
up into two groups
better yet whatever you find along the
way is yours to keep
I wouldn't recommend straying too far
from your fellow ghosts though because
sync shot returns and man is it
satisfying it can require some intricate
planning but pulling off a four person
sync shot might be one of the most
satisfying things this game has to offer
she's dead however it seemed like the
ideal way to play wasn't teams of two
coordinating attacks and sync shots were
much easier that way
number three vehicles are plentiful but
kinda sketchy Bolivia is huge
fortunately you won't have to walk
everywhere every single vehicle in the
game is drivable whether that's a plane
helicopter tank or boat you can get in
it you can even drive a backhoe although
I probably wouldn't initiate a frontal
assault in one of these some of these
vehicles can be a bit squirrely at times
and small trees and fences don't always
break as they should however if you
aren't behind the wheel you can still
deploy drones and scout the area and
shoot out the window number four the map
is huge but looks better from a distance
there are 21 different provinces and 11
different ecosystems populated with
herds of llamas flocks of mingos and all
sorts of other wildlife during our
preview we were only able to explore two
of these provinces but there was no
shortage of armed convoys to ambush
helicopters to steal bases to invade
hostages to secure and weapon boxes
define the environments weather effects
and draw distances were also quite
impressive trying to take a base at
night during a thunderstorm is as
exciting as it should be if you don't
have night-vision equipped you'll have
to rely on the headlights of your
vehicle and the quick flashes of
lightning guiding you to your next
destination however the textures up
close were kind of rough but all of
these details created a unique sandbox
with plenty to do and to see number 5
stealth or hit-and-run Ghost Recon
wildlands is still a tactical shooter
and that means you'll need to be smart
making yourself at home in a
fortification will send you back in a
body bag from what we played it seemed
like the best tactics for either stealth
or hit and run if you plan on sneaking
in you probably want to equip a sniper
rifle and pick off the enemies and
watchtowers get rid of AAA turrets and
maybe shoot up the tires on vehicles so
your targets can escape and in case
you're wondering the sniper rifles do
have bullet drops so be wary of that
then it's time to make your approach
sticking to cover and dispatching your
foes silently when
get the chance is key if you don't have
the patience to do that then I'd be
quick plan a route to get in and out
before the enemy calls in too many waves
of reinforcements the longer you spend
in an enemy base the more time backup
has to arrive on the scene if you do
overstay your welcome the AI pushes back
hard the last thing you want are two
helicopters breathing down your neck as
you're trying to make for the hills
fortunately Ghost Recon plays pretty
well it may not feel as smooth as Metal
Gear Solid 5 or Grand Theft Auto 5 but
it certainly gets the job done during
these 10 situations target down
number six the story starts out slow
probably the most uninteresting thing
about Ghost Recon wildlands in the first
few hours is the story the story is
nonlinear meaning that you can complete
missions in any order this is perfect
for co-op play but didn't make me feel
all that invested in the struggles of my
hero or teammates the AI squad mates
were rather annoying at times as well
thanks to some out-of-place dick jokes
and bad dialogue what do you think I'll
swing you was like as a kid probably
pulled the wings off flies burned ants
with a magnifying glass tight cats over
clotheslines maybe he had a cocaine
stand Junior Achievement
maybe he played violent video games that
[ __ ] the video games make people violent
so what makes people violent other
people take a [ __ ] holster
fortunately wildlands does have drop in
and drop out co-op so you shouldn't have
to deal with them for too long
Ghost Recon wildlands is out March 7th
2017 while the build we played did have
some technical issues wildlands is
shaping up to be an exhilarating co-op
experience for more on Tom Clancy's
Ghost Recon wildlands be sure to tune in
to the lobby which now airs on
Wednesdays at 11 a.m. Pacific and if
you're on YouTube make sure to hit that
subscribe button thank you for watching
hey good work in Mong Kok
[Music]